are you a pedophile no ma'am
there's no history of none of this in my
life
um and now fast forward to this murder
case what do you want to say about that
well i found my wife
in that position you know so it's
unfortunate what i'm going through right
now but
like i say i just need someone to
investigate it you know the
officers said they would do a thorough
investigation
and wish they didn't you know they
clearly told me that
me being the husband i would be the
first suspect in which not a problem
they said they'll do a thorough
investigation they didn't yeah it's just
unfortunate that uh
this is happening this way but like i
say i
definitely feel i prevail in the end
because the facts are the facts
and i have the facts on my side you know
i don't know what occurred i just found
my wife like that
so they're saying they matched
the gps coordinates from your
electronic monitoring bracelet to
the crime scene to
where the body was i was on my way
to henderson hospital on galleria you
know
i do suffer from post-traumatic stress
disorder i had a panic attack
i mean blacks are being killed every day
by the police so i was afraid to call
the police
i pulled over had a panic attack and you
know got out the car
i mean that's not going to show a crime
that just showed that
i took my wife there had a panic attack
got out and ran
did you kill your wife no ma'am
i'm innocent until proven guilty
circumstances and circumstances
i mean someone can say something about
you i can get a whole
media against you but the whole time
it can be a lie you know what's false is
false
everybody can believe something that's
false but at the end of the day is still
false
um do you i guess
when you were granted um permission to
have that
electronic monitoring were you surprised
that you were
given that opportunity or
no i shouldn't even i i feel i shouldn't
even been arrested all they had to do
was investigated
if they investigated they would have
seen who was behind it
you know my wife clearly stepped forward
clearly
you know said it was a bunch of blue we
looked at our videos
of the of where we stayed
there's no such allegations of this we
got eyewitnesses that was there at the
place at the time of the argument you
know
they just went off of that i mean i'm
born and raised out here so when they
heard my name
instantly they jumped on it they didn't
do no investigation
the report was wrote on the 21st i was
arrested on the 22nd
someone did this you know in which they
clearly know someone did this
but they're not even investigating it it
could be difficult
to disprove the information about the
gps coordinates though right with that
ankle monitor
i'm not trying to disprove it i don't
have to disprove that i mean if the gps
had a video on it at the show where i
was at
you know at my home i was in my studio
so i know exactly where i was at
it's just i didn't even supposed to be
at the house at the time because i had
covet
so if you look at my phone which i don't
have no access to my phones or nothing
like that
i called my wife when she got off work
she didn't answer
and that was me heading to the house to
clean it up i cleaned it up on thursdays
and sundays
and she ended up calling me back at 1 30
while i was you know cleaning
and i just gave her a thumbs up so she
the whole time she thinks i'm at the
at the high rise i have to have two
places
who would want to kill your wife then
ma'am that's something that we really
gonna have to find out because i found
my wife like that so there's something
else going on from the point
of me getting my last text and me
finding her
and i'm praying you know stuff this
stuff buzzing up in here you know i mean
i don't know how true it is
i'm trying to get a investigator on that
you know i can't say too much about it
because i don't know for sure but
supposedly
you know someone basically came clean
about a similar situation so
but i can't even get no assistant on
that so when you
called and said something was up and she
said this
man said something to her and gave her a
weird look
that was before you're saying you found
her body or
after i found my wife
after the football game so the football
game was over around eight something
so that's when i found my wife but you
called
9-1-1 at some point right to report
concerns about her so what time did you
call
that was probably around nine but at
that point i'm traumatized i've seen
myself my wife deliver my life
dead
but at no point in that call did you say
you found her right
no and that didn't that call was i was
traumatized i was urged to call
from one of my friends and when she's
like look man just call you know i was
like dude
how am i gonna explain this to the
police you know they're already killing
blacks
you know i mean they're not gonna
believe me he's just like man please
just call just call
a man please call him so i went ahead
and called him and i just
gave them the information from the last
text i gave him but then
in that phone call it makes it seem like
you have no idea what happened to her
well that clearly was proven by the
detectives they said that from
day one that hey we don't believe that
from the gate he said and i'm like you
know dude i was like i say i was
traumatized
they said that from the gate so now my
thing if you don't believe what i'm
saying just investigate what happened
that's all you got to do
they didn't do it
anything how concerned are you that you
are
going to spend the rest of your life
in prison if convicted um
you know some things you just have to
look at when it comes to the law
you know the law is about facts the law
isn't about assumptions
the law isn't about hearsay you know
so an example would be
yes i do have a gps on but this gps
only shows you my coordinates the gps
isn't
eyewitness to anything i
can explain my mental illness it's it's
on record it's on file
i suffer from post-traumatic stress
disorder you can go to my physician
and see that you know but that gps is
the only thing that they're going off of
you still need two eyewitnesses
you still need some type of forensics or
excuse me some type of scientific
scientific evidence in which they took
all of this and they don't
and the fingerprints didn't match up to
be me what do you want
what do you want to say about your wife
i love my wife i miss my wife you know
and i pray
that she's going to prevail through all
of this
that's my wife you know how will she
prevail though
we're gonna find out who killed my wife
uh anything you want to add
uh like i said ma'am i'm just i'm i'm
staying prayed up
and it's gonna work out you know it has
no choice
you know like i say you got people it's
buzzing up in here right now that
someone has
spoken spoke of my or described my
situation
you know so i don't know if this is a
person that's trying to come forward or
what you know but i tried to get some
investigators just to look into that and
nobody did that
so i don't know if this person's still
here no matter what you know so i'm just
praying that
somebody will look into this i mean i
know it looks crazy but
the world looks crazy but the facts
always gonna stand strong
so the friend the friend you talked with
um when after you said you found her
body and the friend said we'll just call
who
wha what's that friend's name
i'm not going to give his name up this
is about me but it's in the records they
have that on file
you know i'm certain he would be one of
their witnesses you know to come in just
to uh
confirm that you know but i'd have no
problem with telling the truth on that
you know
that's i panicked i don't know who's
ever been in a situation like mines
finding the love of their life dead you
know i panicked
i could have did things different now
today that i can sit back and look at it
but you know
having post-traumatic stress disorder
you know and having the fear of the
police killing you
you're gonna do things different and i
did things different